hey Greg before we leave for the movie
can I give you your Christmas present
[Music]
well if you didn't like that president I
got you back up
[Music]
okay how about this one
[Music]
what the [ __ ] right okay I've got one
more and that's it
[Music]
now this I'll watch well we just got
back from Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker always excited talking about a
Star Wars movie fan base is always easy
to communicate really open to opinions
this will not be a spoiler review
there's a lot you can spoil in the final
Skywalker saga film on should I repeat
my Palpatine joke Palpatine joke so so
pop not knows this is the work now yes
the setup is ruined the joke this is my
JJ Abrams mystery box what was the joke
in the past week I binge-watched the
whole Skywalker saga in timeline order
leading up to this because they kept
talking in the marketing about how
they're going to not just wrap up this
new trilogy but wrap up all the movies
and I was like I didn't realize what
they were trying to do with this latest
trilogy after watching this movie I get
why they kept saying that cuz when you
watch the trailers they don't reveal a
whole lot of stuff even the stuff that
we thought they were revealing a little
too much of they're not this is really
of movie that's setting out to be a
culmination of the entire Skywalker saga
franchise the film in and of itself well
I think what JJ Abrams excels at energy
a lot of fun action sequences the whole
time I can honestly say I was genuinely
very entertained there's definitely not
a dull moment in this movie considering
how much is jam-packed it is a one film
at times a little too much movie and I
wonder if on a second viewing if it'll
play a little smoother especially in the
first half of the film yeah this movie
moves at a really quick pace there's a
lot of action in here and there's a lot
of plot if they got a wrap-up add to and
then there's some course correction
stuff and some of that is handled
alright some of that I didn't really
care for the way it was hand I really
the choice of what they did although
some choices it was like oh well I think
the movie succeeds I did really have a
great time with this adventure that
being said are there things in the movie
that I thought were dumb yeah stupid
there's stuff that's not quite clear and
while it goes out of its way to answer a
lot of things there's also like a few
things that are set up in this movie
that are definitely not answered threads
that just tray a lot yeah yeah feels
like the most consequential in a way
not counting the subversions of the last
Jedi but it almost feels like the
average of the first two movies because
there isn't an appropriate amount maybe
more than an appropriate amount of stuff
harkening back to the original Skywalker
trilogy but there are also some new
elements and some surprises that
actually do land there are some things
that were surprises that we're not
really surprised yeah things were like
huh yeah that's surprising that it's
there but it it's technically a surprise
that we're great area
there's JJ Abrams the exciting adventure
filmmaker and then there's the
storyteller JJ Abrams side of things if
Ellie were force awakens he was playing
it safe and this movie kind of rides a
fine balance sort of playing something
safe there are things in here that are
definitely predictable but then there
are times where he just goes fool JJ
Abrams and does some rather unexpected
things and I do think that there are
some great visuals in here the way I
won't go into the Palpatine and how he's
brought back or whatever like that or
what they do with him in this story but
the way they capture Palpatine in here
kind of with this like Star Wars horror
gothic element to it I thought was
visually very impressive and there are
action sequences in here whether it be
the aerial sequences or the lightsaber
fights ETS a lot in the trailer what
with the crashing waves and and rank
high low going at it which I thought was
a really an impressive fight sequence
this version of Rey what they did here
they actually gave her some real
conflict to deal with Daisy Ridley
knocked it out of the park in this oh
yeah I thought she was absolutely
wonderful
yeah I like to clarify that I'm talking
about Daisy Ridley's performance
specifically because in terms of the
writing and development of the Rey
character you know like reveals
abilities and stakes and such and I'll
also say that with Carrie Fisher having
passed and then how they had to recycle
old footage implemented here and then do
some like double standing or whatever I
thought they actually handled it really
well I mean did they maybe one more
screen time and more screen presence in
this one I'm sure they did what they
worked with I thought was very touching
I thought was very effect
so I really commend the film for what
they did here with that Poe Dameron I
think this is the best version we've got
it a Poe Dameron so far what they
explore with him and he just gets a lot
more screen presence and more to do and
I actually think the group that they
have with Rey Finn and Poe and Threepio
and Chewie I thought was great chemistry
there I loved seeing all of them hang
out together yeah and it makes it feel
like we have come very far on this
journey with them since 2015 that was
one of my favorite aspects is that even
though you could look at the plot and
say that certain characters have less to
do than the others I thought that
everybody's presence just brought
something even with Finn who has
arguably still the least to do I think
this is my favorite integration of him
through the past three films because at
least he's an active member of the
resistance and he has the least
operations to go and handle you know I
felt like for certain plot things that
Finn had to do he was essential I think
as a character not much of a character
in this one yeah I felt like he mainly
had a funny line or he yelled someone's
name like it was one of the two things
that he did there's some dialogue that I
really did not like in this movie I know
you got a lot to jam in here you got a
whole lot of movie fanservice overload
maybe could have benefited from an extra
30 to 45 minutes I personally would have
minded even though the movies already
pretty long this is the final Skywalker
saga film like sure why not let's all
stick around a little longer and I think
in terms of the dialogue especially in
the first half of this movie second half
plays a lot better to me than the first
half it's not prequel bad dialogues it's
not gonna knows great I'm in a way that
isn't up to the par of the rest of the
right especially what they do with like
kylo kylo Ren I love Adam driver when
he's not wearing the mask when he wears
the mask I just don't think they know
how to write for that version of kylo
none of these films especially the
second but in this one what he's not
wearing the mask are these great but
what he's wearing the mask I just don't
care for the character there's some
qualms to have with the way of what they
do with the Emperor overall you know
just seeing he and McDormand back in the
rolling he just kills it as just always
a blast to watch you know icky and scary
like yeah they really did play up the
horror and the evil yeah inside of him
and the Sith in general and they they do
illustrate
the battle between the Jedi and the Sith
in a compelling way
I thought Threepio was a whole lot of
fun in this movie Lando is not treated
with the same essential quality as when
we brought back the original three main
stars he's more of a glorified cameo
yeah yeah like he does stuff he's not
just there but he's not of much of an
essential piece and the way the other
three players were there are choices in
this movie that are definitely gonna
have people really split I think there
are some choices that are bold and there
are some choices that personally is
someone who just watch the whole
franchise thought work um especially in
terms of some of the rules and the
muddiness of those rules my last
interruption Barret eyes or my eyes were
just rolling and there are moments where
you could tell half the crowd was loving
a certain reveal or choice there are
other parts where I was at the crowd
like oh I think an extra 30 to 40
minutes of this already long epic film
what actually would have been okay reads
a little better and earn a few more
things there's a lot to talk about in
spoilers I think overall as an
experience in the theaters it's a it's a
really good at space adventure time and
I think that's what JJ really excels at
plot point wise character choice wise
some things I agree with some things I
really don't agree with and the way the
scripting was done that I thought was a
little silly but I did quite enjoy
myself watching I don't know if I loved
it but I certainly had a great time when
I was watching it yeah I mean I was just
kind of relieved that it was to my eyes
pretty solid and yeah consistently fun
consistently engaging I wasn't really
overcome with emotion at any point but I
was always pulled in and invested in
what was going on you know rooting for
our heroes enjoying some of the gray
areas of the story there were times
where I was really swept up I have no
idea how people gonna react to this
movie it's one of those movies where you
got to kind of watch it twice I would
imagine once to get the angst out of
your system of all the lead-up and then
you know the second time you can see it
with kind of even eyes if you guys have
come this far with the franchise you
should definitely watch this one it does
put an ending no ton on it all keep a
lookout for our spoiler talk do you want
the Skywalker saga franchise to end do
you think it should be handed off to
Warner Brothers do you think this should
just be rebooted and just do George
Lucas's original true
oh gee plant if the Wills subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell and keep a lookout for our spoiler
talk because it's gonna be a thick one